[Music]
these men are fugitives from Mexico
please and should be that's not true sir
all I do is screw his daughter guys that
beat you hitting your mentee knows all
I'm just passing through my wedding big
kill my brother owns a saloon there
really even brothels that sounds like my
kind of town we were planning on heading
that direction perhaps we can ride with
you I certainly wouldn't mind the
company this time I settled down become
an honorable citizen let's not go that
far too big kill ain't much of a green
town
I know you you're Jake and Travis who
are you Johnny Kane never heard of it
that man they came up to you last night
is he all talk no he's a killer
Goodwin we don't seem very welcome we're
used to that I do believe that I have
found the woman of my dreams of the
preacher what's your business here
just passing through see you till you
pass through quickly I need to find out
what happened my brother there's
something I gotta do I'm new in town
that's me
what's happened in town here you said
this place was booming
I see people being gunned down in the
streets business was booming and then
the mines flooded and people lost
everything town wasn't bad
just some of the people this is not how
we get things done this is exactly how
we get things done nobody runs me out of
my town you're coming for us we gotta
get out of here
I'm not going you stay here they'll kill
you I know we're gonna get shot at yep
[Music]
[Music]
I'm tired to get him run out of every
town we go I'm gonna make you stand for
something
unless confessions my soul's it piece is
yours
you
you